[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Google Cloud Drawing
Board, where we doodle
our way through the cloud.
Today's topic-- what
is Compute Engine?
Simply put, it refers to
customizable virtual machines
running in Google Cloud.
You can select the right
machine for your needs
from predefined or
custom machine types.
Predefined machines come with
general-purpose combinations
of CPU and memory.
But if those don't
meet your needs,
then you can choose the
custom machine types, which
allow the selection
of exact number of CPU
and amount of memory you
need for your workloads.
There are three different
machine-type families-- general
purpose, compute optimized,
and memory optimized.
General purpose
machines are best
suited for general workloads,
like web servers and databases.
If you're not sure which
family you should choose,
just choose general
purpose instances.
It is recommended to use
compute optimized machines
for compute-intensive
applications,
such as high-performance
computing, gaming,
electronic design automation,
and single-threaded apps.
If you have
memory-intensive workloads,
such as in-memory databases, SAP
HANA, or real-time analytics,
use memory-optimized instances.
And you can add graphical
processing units
to accelerate
computationally-intensive
workloads, like machine
learning or medical analysis.
Now, how do you
use Compute Engine?
Well, it's easy.
Just select the type of
machine and where you want it,
and the instance gets
created for your use
in that specific location.
There are some features
of Compute Engine
that make it an awesome choice.
It allows for live
migration, so your app
can keep running
during maintenance mode
without interruptions.
It provides sizing
recommendations.
For example, if you are
using a bigger instance
for a workload that can
run on a smaller instance,
then you can save costs
using these recommendations.
And for your
container workloads,
it supports deployment
of containers.
Now, what does it cost
to use Compute Engine?
It is simple.
You pay for what you use.
But you can save costs by taking
advantage of some discounts.
Sustained-use savings
are automatic discounts
applied for running instances
for a significant portion
of the month.
If you know your
usage upfront, you
can take advantage of
committed-use discounts, which
can lead up to 57% savings
without any upfront cost.
And by using short-lived,
preemptible instances,
you can save up to 80%.
These are great for batch jobs
and fault-tolerant workloads.
Along with lots of
other use cases,
like running websites and
databases on Compute Engine,
you can also use it to
migrate your existing systems
into Google Cloud, or even
run Windows applications
by bringing your own
licenses or using
the included licensed images.
To noodle more on
Compute Engine,
check out
cloud.google.com/compute.